The Joe Rogan Experience
oh my God he's on top
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God look at these
Rippers
okay oh my God
this is incredible this is [__]
incredible Brandon's shop oh my God
vulcanovsky is a [__] Savage I stand
corrected volganovsky is the goat no no
you better catch them oh my God let me
back out let me back oh my God look at
this 35 seconds ago all he has to do is
not get submitted and stay on top and
he's the [__] double champ
you're damn right holy [__] how you
can't say he's the goat he's the guy
he's the goat he's the problem
[__] unreal look at this I'm glad I'm
beating him up I'm glad I lost he's got
it 15 seconds to go he's got it
that's all you gotta look oh look at
this
is the winner oh my God look at this
Point 100
.
[__] what a [__] fight man oh my God
what a [__] oh my God he beat him he
[__] beat him
he beat Islam in Australia that is
insane and and avoided his take and got
on time and he was deep and then rocked
him down
he's so baffled he won't give it to
democracy if I promise you they won't
and it's guarantee the markets have
never saw that come it's impossible I
never thought that the end of the fight
would be him on his [__] back this
was the fight this was this this is
everything what a scramble that scramble
was everything it's so huge wrestlers
[__] look at this boom look at that left
hand dude I I missed the one where he
dropped them right there right there oh
my goodness
beating him up here at the end of the
fight I lost two thousand dollars on you
or are you just like a wild game boy hey
hey this is wild gambling
matchup transitions from the back to the
arm bars yeah
he did it he did it Eddie you're saying
you need Brazilian jiu-jitsu I can't
believe he did it dude he is just
underworldly
freak assessed it okay this guy's heart
attack
that's a regular game and he probably is
walking around at 165 pounds it's
probably yeah yeah I don't think I've
ever been I mean smaller I've never been
prouder of a fighter oh my God look at
my chef he's so distraught he realizes
now he just [__] lost 100 percent
dude that was a hell of a fight
that was a hell of a fight let's do this
they'll probably have to run it back huh
eventually let's hear it
48 47.
volkanovski
new
oh wow oh wow oh that's insane that's
insane
he got [__] robbed I got to see my
two girls
[__] what the [__] I still win my money
um
vocal on that fight we were just we were
convinced were we too biased we might
have been biased we might have to watch
it I don't know I mean I don't I was
very biased well let's see what the
online people think because it was I
thought it was three two three two yeah
I thought it was two two golden that's
crazy oh my God this sucks
listen to the crowd
show the champion some respect these
[__] judges man they they ruined
history one of those scorecards was
crazy
maybe it's tall poppy syndrome
many things happen before the fight
excuses yeah he's already he's like like
he lost he knows he lost bro he lost
that fight I believe me too
Eddie you think you lost the fight
I think it was three to two Brian what's
that who do you think won the fight I I
Gotta Give it to Volk I think so too
because maybe it's hard we're watching
it obviously we're not scoring it
legitimately I would say it seems like
the audience agrees with this but
they're in Australia I think we're
better judges than those [__] morons
we're talking [__] and we're drinking I
mean it seemed to me though that he won
three rounds we were 40 we were pretty
convinced he caught folk way more in the
face way more did more damage he did a
lot more damage on Volk he hit him a lot
more a lot more think about it
and he took him down everybody's trying
to justify your best he took him down so
here's what he did 96 significant
strikes to 141 for volcanovsky
you're wrong significant strikes 57
takedowns though huge the four takedowns
were big knockdowns yeah knock down
significant strikes out yeah total
strikes outstruck them
I yeah he did get one knock down he
landed almost as many as he threw I
didn't see that total strikes I think
that's [__] wow those were from the
ground though probably when he was yeah
right still count still counts then you
got to get to just what is the online
World thing second I haven't got a lot
of results I gotta think the online
world's going crazy right now I've only
got two people I mean it's so it's hard
I don't want to be disrespectful I'm one
of the biggest Islam jock Riders ever I
was saying before you know that he was
the guy that everybody was or not I've
never been really I'm I'm just not
convinced because he doesn't have the
level of difficulty like the other guys
well this was a high level of difficulty
and he lost and I I feel like he should
have lost but I don't now I'm a fan but
I just thought we're gonna have to get
it done
what did volcanowski say
he's not even breathing hard
very classy
present the hardest fight well Martinez
such a hard man but it's so crazy when
you watch our response we're like 100
convinced and new yeah